let's bring in Labor's retina Allen Khan
who is also a doctor and you've worked
in the Health Service just to describe
for his
um what your colleagues are telling you
about how the Health Service is right
now yes well I'm still a practicing a e
doctor I'm working on Sunday and my most
recent shift was actually over the
Christmas period so what I'm seeing is
what my colleagues are echoing around
the country which is that they feel
unfortunately that this is the worst
they've ever seen the NHS for patients
and for staff and unfortunately we are
now at the point where Staff feel they
cannot provide safe and dignified care
and we now know that up to 500 people
per week are going to die because they
cannot receive the emergency care that
they so desperately need so it is a very
very difficult time Staffing morale's at
rock bottom but really and truly it it's
very difficult to go to work feeling as
though you have one arm tied behind your
back and you cannot do your job properly
for your patients I mean this what's
this come down to then this comes down
to the the lack of funding there's also
the demographic
um pressures as well on the on the
Health Service
I think there there are a number of
issues we have had 12 years of political
choices that have resulted in us already
having an under-resourced NHS with no
slack in the system undoubtedly uh
covid-19 and and the flu have caused
extra pressure this winter but this
isn't a news flash for the government
they knew this was coming we used to
call it winter pressures but that
actually felt as it as as though it
lasted all year for the last few years
and we had a government when they had
the summer that they could have been
planning for flu and for covid and for
strepe they didn't they were too busy
infighting and trying to find a new
leader and now we have a situation where
people are having intimate examinations
in cupboards
patients are waiting up to 99 hours in
in an ambulance in an a e Bay unable to
get a bed inside the hospital we're
having children sleeping on plastic
chairs patients lying on Floors being
examined on floors with sheets held up
by nurses we're we're at a crisis that's
quite much with the uh with a labor
government increase NHS funding
well this isn't this is um a
hypothetical question because we're not
in government what we have what we have
is a Workforce plan we have an excellent
Workforce plan because we understand
that the workforce is the front and
center and the Heart and Soul of our NHS
we would train an extra 10 000 nurses
and midwives every year we would double
the number of medical school places we
would have 5 000 extra Health visitors
we will improve our Mental Health
Services ensuring that people can access
treatment they need within a month and
we have a plan for this but what we have
right now is an acute crisis that the
government needs to get on top of they
can't blame the twindemic for the fact
that we have patients who are lying on
Hospital floors and you'd fund all of
that by what increasing taxational
people we would fund our Workforce plan
by by taxing private schools by um by uh
by ensuring that we can raise 1.6
billion pounds for our Workforce plan so
we have a full costed Workforce plan
which we are confident will help but
it's also about retaining the staff that
we have got and understanding that we
have a hundred and thirty thousand
vacancies now so it is going to take a
mammoth a mammoth effort But ultimately
what people watching today want to know
is if their loved one is having a stroke
or or a heart attack can they get the
ambulance that they need
if your child is unwell can you get the
antibiotics that you need and currently
the answer is no so increasing taxes in
some sectors will be one way of getting
extra stuff what about reform of the NHS
what about reforming the system properly
I mean that is look you can see it's not
working it isn't working and you know we
have a fantastic Shadow Health secretary
who who talks about the need for that
and and
ultimately being a service is not a
shrine do you agree with those words
we need to reform the NHS because it
isn't working in its current form is it
it isn't ultimately right now there is a
very real chance that 500 people a week
are going to die because they can't get
access to the care that they need people
can't get GP appointments people are
having intimate examinations in
cupboards staff are leaving in their
droves it's not working I mean what part
of his critique was that GPS voted not
to extend their working hours past five
o'clock in the evening before 9 A.M do
you agree that that should be looked at
Again by by the union the doctors Union
of the BMA he's having his own
discussions with the BMA I'm not privy
to those conversations what I can say is
we have a system that isn't working and
we have a plan to appreciate that
because you you are a doctor so I am a
doctor do you agree with those ideas
that perhaps doctors can can do a little
bit more to help alleviate some of that
pressure look ultimately everybody can
play a part in improving the system but
currently doctors and nurses are broken
they are absolutely broken two-thirds of
Junior doctors want to leave the
workforce we have nurses leaving in
droves we have more mental health sick
days taken than even covered or flu from
medical staff we have a system that's
broken we have people who are who are
absolutely overworked and on their knees
but I'll tell you one thing we have
something in medical school called the
my mum test which is when you graduate
and you're smiling because maybe you've
heard about it if you've heard of it you
want to know that you are providing the
level of care that you hope and pray
that someone will provide your mum no
one at the moment goes to work feeling
as though any of the patients they see
would pass the my mum test and that is a
very very sad State of Affairs and
ultimately it is an indictment of the
failure of this government to get on top
of the issues of the NHS that we are
having a death rate associated with not
being able to access care and I
appreciate that and everyone will
appreciate all the pressures they're
facing but I do want to get from you
some of the ideas that a potential labor
government would bring in and let's
stick with Junior doctors just for a
second you know that Junior doctors are
going to be balloted next week about
strike action yes at a time like this
for junior doctors to take strike action
what does that say about the way that
they want to work in the service nobody
wants to take strike action and what we
need is the government to get around the
table so that that doesn't actually
happen so I'm I'm hoping that no one has
to go on strike if they voted for it
well I'm not eligible to be balloted and
I'm never going to tell somebody what
they should or shouldn't do when they're
feeling as though they cannot provide
Safe Care to their patients But
ultimately I don't want junior doctors
to go on strike Junior doctors don't
want to go on strike patients don't want
junior doctors to go on strike we need a
government to sit at the table and have
the discussions this this is a mess of
the government's own making and if they
don't they could go on strike you're
asking me a hypothetical question and it
hasn't happened so thank you
I wasn't sure
I'm just saying that well you know it is
hypothetical but you could answer if you
wanted to look let's talk about nurses
then nurses have got a paid demand that
we all hear about 19 do you think it's
wise for them to bring down that paid
event to perhaps unstick these
negotiations well they've asked for the
government to sit down and meet with
them and the government currently
haven't it's it's always a negotiation
isn't it people start at the summit they
want people coming lower they have a
discussion and and that is what needs to
happen
um but ultimately it is an unprecedented
move for nurses to strike it it's it's a
historic event that none of them want to
do particularly when there's a cost of
living crisis we already have nurses
that actually need to use food banks to
go another day without pay they don't do
that lightly but I I cannot
um stress enough to you that the
situation we face at the moment with
nurses that are going in to work they
are they are feeling as though they are
not giving dignified Safe Care to their
patients and that is huge and when you
go to work with that burden you have to
understand the toll that that takes when
you know that your patient may not be
getting the medication that they need
may not be getting the level of care
that they need may not be getting that
you know stroke treatment within the
four hour window you have a patient
coming in who's reliant on you and you
know that because of because of delays
they haven't been able to to not have
the symptoms of not being able to talk
again move again that that is a very
soul-destroying experience for NHS staff
okay Dr Rosetta allenkind we will leave
it there thank you so much thank you
very much